pleased to have here on the rich eisen
show a man who is starring in the film
dangerous that uh is out there in
theaters and on demand starring mel
gibson scott eastwood
famke johnson and kevin durant with a d
not it's not kevin durant that's a big
yes i know it's a big difference uh here
on the mercedes-benz vans phone line is
none other than tyrese gibson how are
you tyrese
i'm good man good morning to you sir no
good morning to you as well um this is
not a surprise to me that your voice
does sound great man i got to be honest
with you it's coming through right now
yeah your voice is great too man
compliments to you too sir i appreciate
it well i've got this big microphone in
front of me you're talking in front of a
landline right this is this sounds like
yeah
you're an adult
you know you're an adult you have a
landline you've got a voice you're going
to ready to roll i love it um no no i'm
i'm talking to you from my cell phone
i'm sorry wow wow jeez okay i like it i
like it very much um how did you get
into acting how did that first start for
you
tyrese
john singleton
rest in peace
was the guy that
you know um
i think we've all had that moment
where
um
we either see something we're exposed to
something
or someone says something and they're
like i see something in you that you may
not see in yourself
and at the time
you know i was only a singer
and i was so excited about my singing
career
the last thing i wanted to do was act
and um
you know they always say if you want to
make god laugh tell them your plans so
i guess
i guess there was something i was
supposed to do that i was running from
or never just set still and heavily
considered
and um john singleton
chased me literally chased me for five
years
and just kept saying
you're gonna be an actor i'm gonna put
you in a movie and
he did that to so many people from ice
cube to nia long to you name it
morris chestnut
just a lot of people that he ended up
putting on um
who made their debut and a film that he
directed and i was one of the lucky ones
so fast forward
as i get this call about dangerous
on the other side of him passing away
coming up on three years now
when i book movies
it feels different now because
he would always be the first person i
would call oh boy
and i would call him throughout the
shoot or just talk to him about
you know we gotta do this scene man any
advice you know he was constantly
mentoring me
and um you know you never miss a good
thing till it's gone
but yeah this dangerous movie is is
something man
well
i just want to linger a bit with on john
singleton before we get to the present
day as well tyrese so um why did he have
to chase you down don't you say yes to
john singleton
right away no
i knew who he was but
this might sound ghetto as hell might be
crazy sure
but my truth is
i'm from south central l.a
and when you in the hood
they always talk a lot of mess about
people who go hollywood
oh he acting all hollywood
and then after i did my first movie
the only reason i did it is because my
character was from south central l.a
it was a ghetto classic we felt it at
the time while we were making it
and i felt like
all my boys i grew up with
would never say i went hollywood because
i was doing a movie that was about the
hood
um
and then
later on as i got into the industry
i realized that hollywood is not a
career
it's a personality type
and people are arrogant cocky
act like they're bigger and better than
everybody the nose is up in the air he
acting on hollywood
was something that they could say about
anybody you could be in real estate you
can be a thousand there a millionaire
and if you start acting
brand new
bougie or out of touch
then that's a personality type
that they call hollywood
so
it was the stupidest thing in the world
like i ain't never seen to do no movies
they ain't gonna call me hollywood
but
that was my reason
and uh john talked me into it it just
goes to show you man that
should never listen
to people on any level that's trying to
discourage you from taking advantage of
opportunities and
who would ever think um i'd be working
with
you know
mayo gibson
who i grew up watching
ever since i sing passion to the christ
i just was like man one day i just hope
to share the screen with this man
and here we are
um
i work with with kevin durand
we did a film called legion
um me him and dennis quaid so it was
cool to reconnect with him
and um i worked with scott eastwood as
well on fast eight
um so
yeah it was it felt like a bit of a
homecoming and
it was uh it was a moment you know my
last name was gibson his last name was
gibson
that's right
pretty cool
gibson no doubt about that um tyrese
gibson here on the rich eisen show what
did you like about dangerous what do you
like what should we be
looking forward to seeing in this one i
mean you know the gist of the movie is
scotty eastwood
is trying to get to the bottom of who
killed his brother
and he's literally sociopath
um who
has to take medicine
because he just doesn't he's a he's a
sociopath and um
uh
you know he just kind of goes through
this whole movie on this journey trying
to get to the bottom of who killed his
brother
and um
i can't give the whole movie away but
it's it's one of them thrillers
trying to avenge his brother's death is
something crazy
it's available in theaters uh right now
on demand uh tyree skips in here on the
rich eisen show so um
what's your sports affiliation lakers
would you go lakers
dodgers
i'm not a big sports guy but if i do
rock with sports it's definitely lakers
okay well cause i i i thought you know
and i i've done this for a long time in
the sports world for about 25 years
virtually every uh um singer recording
artist wants to be a sports star and
vice versa you know that never that
never hit you that never not me not you
okay no way all right no way really that
never that never hit you because it's
just striking yeah i haven't i mean this
is sadly
if i watch a
football game it's normally super bowl
sure
if i watch baseball games normally
pieces of
you know the world series
so i live in atlanta now and so
obviously i was definitely
watching bits and pieces of that game
okay
and and feel
really proud of the braves
now that i live here
but i'm a laker fan
always been from the beginning of time
magic johnson
um
kobe to lebron now
it's definitely
um
my favorite team
tyreese gibson here on the rich eisen
show tyreese we play uh with celebrity
guests on this program a game called
celebrity true or false we have a couple
of facts here from your uh
from your uh i guess filmography as well
as articles that have been written uh
about you i just want to know what's
true and false if you don't mind we even
have some uh we even have something to
go for okay here we go we even have some
some good production value to it go
ahead hit it please
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth okay here we go uh first one
up is it true or false you bought your
first house at age 16. is that a true or
false story
is this from uh from money from uh from
film career singing what was it
for you my singing yeah i got my record
deal
after i did my coke commercial your
co-commercials
how did you get into a cult commercial
as a teenager how did that work they
called my high school
come on said they were looking for male
black 16 through 18 for a cult
commercial and
i was the last person to show up for the
audition and i got to get changed my
life
so okay so you're just walking through
the halls of your high school and
somebody pulls you aside and says that
hey we got a call no they called they
called the music department okay and you
were in the music department yes sir
okay so you've always you've always been
attracted to music right i guess then
music is my first love still to this day
so what did you do in that coke
commercial
what'd you do i'm singing on the bus i
got a backpack on and the way the
commercial ends i end up with a really
big smile at the end
wearing headphones in the backpack it's
a
very very very famous commercial changed
my life when i was
um 15
and
um
my mother had the co-sign on the house
because you got to be at least 21 to own
a property in california
and
she co-signed and i bought the house wow
life-changing commercial now you live in
atlanta home of coca-cola it's pretty
amazing yeah yeah
how about that uh second one true or
false
true or false tyrese gibson you have a
big-time fear of owls
is that true or false true
why
why why do you have a fear of owls i
just don't like them it's no different
than people that don't like rats
it's a majestic bird for many people
though tyrese yeah well not for me
okay
all right uh next up um when you were
growing up you dreamed of becoming a
trash collector when you were a young
child is that a true story
as well very true
okay
what did what did what appealed to you
just the truck and working hard or i
just you know
anything that feels alpha for me
from childhood
all my big homies were alphas
everything i know about
what i identify with as a real man is is
an alpha and
i just thought
there's a lot of jobs out there but it
takes a real man a real alpha to be
picking up trash and at the time
this was long before people were
pulling up to the trash can and it has
the automatic thing that kind of picks
it up yeah forklift and yeah it was like
this is when real men was like pulling
up and
you know they wore their back braces and
they was lifting that trash up and doing
their thing so i used to go like
10 houses up the street
i put on like three or four belts around
my waist regular belts yeah and
every week i just would help the trash
man
and that's what i wanted to be
that was long before i ever knew i could
sing
long way long before
any thought of acting
and um
yeah i knew that they had medical and
dental benefits and
there you go i was like coming home
every day smelling like trash had to be
pretty sexy to your girlfriend or your
wife
uh and so that's what i wanted to do
all right the last one for you here on
celebrity true or false tyrese gibson
true or false you you have a fully
functioning benihana style restaurant
located right in your backyard and you
call it gibsy hana is that your story
it's true and you can google it
videos his photos
i've been um partying in that thing for
the last 10 years
so do you do you operate it yourself do
you
do you chop things up yourself all my
employees are from bernie hans
like
like you give straight to the fruit of
the vine is what you're saying you go
straight to the benihana and then you
get them in and they they do their thing
for you in your backyard yeah yeah it's
called poaching
okay i uh i've i've definitely poached
it the thing is
i've been doing this for years and i you
know i don't mean no disrespect to the
benihana
empire
but
if
if i'm ever looking for someone to do
something
i normally show up to their job where
they're doing what i want them to do for
me
and then i'll just ask them let me get
your phone number
i don't want you to leave your job
but here and there i'm going to call you
and see if you want to take advantage of
this opportunity i mean i even you can
google this as well i even built a full
cleaners
with the iron and press steam i built
the full cleaners in my garage
um they actually did a story on it on
tmz which is kind of random but yeah
um uh-huh
yeah so
it's just one of those things where my
brain has always been
if i see it if i like it if i want it
then i'm gonna do it
and
um
the idea came from
a complaint that i've heard from most of
my celebrity vip friends
that we can't go nowhere can't eat
nowhere can't do anything especially in
la
because the paparazzi and the cameras is
always messing with so
i i don't want to name drop but if you
can think of anybody who's a b and c
list star
director writer producer you name it all
eight in my backyard and we've had some
of the most legendary parties
and um it's been amazing the crazy thing
is i'm actually selling the house right
now
and that's the hardest part about
letting the house go
so many moments that um
you know so many moments michael bay
john singleton
just you name it paul walker first time
i used it
first time i built it was for my
daughter's fifth birthday
and she's 14 now
and so if you pull up an image right now
and you type in gifsi hana you'll see an
image of paul walker vindies or will
smith
with his daughter
all sitting in my backyard at bendy
honestly that has to be legendary that
hasn't been the legendary and then
across from paul walker and then yeah
was actually dexter and bernice king
who was the son and daughter of martin
luther king and coretta scott king all
of this happened on the debut
the first time i ever built it and used
it and so i knew that i was like if
we're starting this way it's only up
from here
[Laughter]
i should say so and it's too bad i never
got there too because i'll be honest
with you tyreese i'm a messy eater so if
i'd gotten something on my shirt you're
telling me i could have gone in your
garage and got it fully cleaned and
laundered and pressed yeah as well we
could have got you all the way right
pressed you up
wow put you on a regular t-shirt so we
took care of you
and then had that thing delivered to you
here's the thing i even had the plastic
to go on top so once we press it
put the plastic on
it was full service baby you should
google all this stuff man i don't lie
don't a lot of my friends all right
you know make stuff up man it's it's i
went all out and then i went and poached
like four people that work at the
cleaners
it's like you know if you work five days
a week man just come see me on saturday
take care of you
everything in my house
i put i spend so much money on the
cleaners every year because there's
certain things that you just can't put
in the washing machine that's true like
man i'm not spending all this money
i'm gonna hire this guy i'm gonna pay
him per hour
and he's just gonna get me right with
every suit
button up and pants and everything you
name it and you work at the cleaners so
you know how to operate all this stuff
in here
yes sir where have you been all my life
tyrese oh my god this is fantastic i
really am inspired by every word that's
dropping out of your mouth right now
this is amazing uh yeah dangerous in
theaters and on demand check it out with
uh tyreese gibson mel gibson kevin
durand
famke johnson and scott eastwood uh this
has been announced
if i'll mention one thing
please of course we want you guys to go
see
dangerous um
but i wanted to mention
one of the proudest things i've ever
done in my life okay
is launch
voltron
voltrontravel.com
v-o-l-t-r-o-n travel dot com okay every
booking hotel
flight
or car rental
every booking we're shaving off a
percentage
to put black and brown people through
college at hbcus
um the proudest thing i've ever done
so with all of the holiday travel that's
coming up
um
please go to voltrontravel.com
and you can go and book anywhere i get
it but
when you book with me
you're making a difference and we're
putting
black and brown people through college
with full scholarships
the underserved and it's the proudest
thing i've ever done and i just wanted
to make sure i mentioned that before we
go it's fantastic
voltrontravel.com tj you wanted to hop
in here yeah i just had a quick question
tyreese what up man this is tj
what up man so you brought up baby boy
earlier right and so now i'm thinking
the the the benihana and the dry cleaner
right is that
falling to the guns category or the
butter category like you know ving rings
talked about the guns in the butter so
which one of these categories does
do these two fall into the thing it's a
good one here's the thing
um
one thing i never look forward to is an
invoice from benihana
um
and so
me paying that one chef
uh
and feeding damn near
200 people per night
um i would think that it would fall into
um
the butter
category
there's your answer
the amount of money i was looking to
save from my cleaners every month
sheets and bedding and clothes
it's butter saving money
um so yeah that's that's my answer there
you go that's what's up this is great
tyrese gibson let's do this more often
whenever you want to promote anything i
this chat has just been delightful and
it's been awesome so thanks for the call
i really appreciate it let's do this
again hey man thank you for having me on
and thank you guys for your great energy
this is my first interview of the day
excellent so i'm off to a good start
there we go no doubt there we go i hate
to tell you and and i don't mean to slag
on anybody else in my business it's all
downhill from here for you unfortunately
[Music]
a slice of all
the bookings goes towards putting as he
said people of color into hbcus where
our friend dion sanders currently
coaches college football so uh
and it's via the third good marshall
foundation as well it's been around for
well over 75 years fantastic they're my
partner to make sure that all the money
from the bookings are going
to put folks through college so i'm just
very very proud and while i'm on the air
i'm like you know
i probably couldn't afford this
conversation um but now that we're on
the airwaves
i just hope y'all definitely book with
us you got it voltrontravel.com
dangerous in theaters tyrese gibson
thank you sir you be well
thank you you got you tyrees gibson
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here